Imagine you're an
Economics student
and it's the start
of the academic year.
You're sitting in one of these
chairs in the lecture venue
and your lecturer is talking
about changes in unemployment
rates and productivity.
and brings up this graph from
your economics textbook showing
the trends in change over time.
Well, having just
lived through 2020,
you likely know
someone or know someone
who knows someone,
who lost their job
due to the COVID pandemic.
And your eyes immediately averse
to this part of the graph.
What's going on here?
What would this
graph look like if we
could include more recent data?
Wouldn't it be great
if your lecturer
could draw on a relevant,
recent experience
to make the teaching
more engaging
and also have the textbook
resources to support this?
The problem is this figure
from an economics textbook
was manually produced
in proprietary software
where each element
was individually
placed by a designer
according to their stylesheet.
It is very time
intensive and expensive.
Updating and reproducing
figures such as this
is one of the key
contributing factors
to the really slow revision
cycles of such a textbook.
Our world is rapidly
advancing and changing
and although we may
have the data available,
our educational
resources quickly
become outdated, and likely
stay so for several years.
This is not a
problem that is only
common to the educational
publishing industry.
How can we invigorate
such a traditional process
to overcome this?
My name is Megan Beckett,
I'm a data scientist
from Cape Town, South Africa.
And I'd like to tell you about
how we at Exegetic Analytics
partnered with a
publishing company
in order to prototype a pipeline
to automatically produce
figures for an
economics textbook.
There are thousands
of these images
and each has been
meticulously, manually
handmade by the designers
according to their stylesheet.
The first question the
publishing house came to me
with was, can you
automate this so
that we can easily update them?
Well, with R and the
Tidyverse, of course we can.
The first step in the
process was therefore
to figure out an
automated pipeline.
We started out with
the data in Excel files
and various other sources
which are ingested into Google
Sheets as a central repository.
The reason for using Google
Sheets instead of a database
was that we still
wanted it to be easily
accessible to
non-technical users
so they could also access the
data and update it as needed.
Each figure is being governed
by a central R script where
the data is read in, the
figure produced in ggplot,
and then the main
output focus was SVG.
However, with such
an automated workflow
we can also output
multiple formats,
useful in the various publishing
platforms, whether it's iPad,
print, or the web.
Furthermore by taking
advantage of the plotly library
and adding a single line
of code to R scripts,
we can also create interactive
versions of each figure
for the web, further
enhancing the teaching
and learning experience.
This entire process is
wrapped up within R package
with several helper functions
to help automate this pipeline.
We we get to integrating
with the publishing houses
processes.
This will likely become an API.
So we tick the box
of figuring out
how to automate this pipeline
so that the graphs can
be easily updated.
But the next question
they came with was, well,
can you make them look
as good as our originals?
As publishers, it was
very important to them
that the figures look
good for teaching,
that they comply to
their style guidelines,
and that they were
virtually indistinguishable
from the originals.
The second part of
the project therefore
focused on the aesthetics.
And this is where ggplot
really came to the party.
And it's also a
part of the project
that I thoroughly enjoyed.
On the left hand side here,
you can see an example piece
from the stylesheet that the
designers worked with in order
to produce the figures.
This needed to be
translated into code.
The vast majority of the
aesthetics of the figures
was controlled with a
custom ggplot theme.
You are shown a simplified
version on the right hand side
to demonstrate what
I'm talking about.
We started out with
the base classic theme
and then built upon that.
Where each specification in
the visual style sheet
was translated into code as
a specification to the theme.
For example, the font families,
the point sizes, colors
and lines, and even the spacing
around all of the elements.
It really is quite
incredible how much
you can control the output
of your ggplot figures.
I'd like to show you some of
the outputs of what we achieved.
On the left hand side, you can
see the original meticulously
manual plot.
The purpose here is not to read
and understand these graphs
but rather to make a
comparison between this
and the aesthetically automated.
This here is an example
from the beginning,
from the economics lecture
with an additional plot below.
If you do spot any
differences, please do tweet me
as I do really love doing this.
Here is a second example, and
what I want to point out here
are some deliberate differences.
You might have noticed this in
the previous graph as well,
but there are some
dotted lines, blue lines
that show the trends for
different time periods.
When I calculated
these trends from the data
and plotted them on the graph.
I noticed a stark
difference particularly
for the 18th century
as indicated here.
What I realized then is that
the designer had visually
looked at the data and
placed the trend line by hand
according to what
they thought was best.
This is very error prone.
So not only is our plot on the
right aesthetically automated
but it is also more
accurate than the original
as it is derived
directly from the data.
This third example
was really quite
a fun challenge to solve
specifically around the layout
and how we placed these
dotted gray lines extending
from points on the top graph
to corresponding points
on the bottom graph.
As I mentioned, about 80% of
the aesthetics of the plots
was achieved with
a ggplot theme.
However, here I also use the
gridextra, ggtext, and gtable
packages which really power
the layout engine of ggplot.
I was able to get into the
underlying grobs and grid
in order to produce
such a layout.
I really was quite
proud of this image.
This last example here
shows some trend lines
for different cities.
What I want you to
take note of there
are the icons used in the
legend called key glyphs.
These are not standard key
glyphs that come with ggplot.
Typically each geom has
an associated function
that would draw the key glyphs
in the legend if it's required.
So for example, geom point has
a key function called draw,
and a score key,
and score point that
will then add points to the
legend as icons if needed.
So what we did was
look at the ggplot code
for how these key glyph
functions work and create
some of our own custom functions
to manually draw these icons.
So for example, this
one is a key path
with a key symbol placed on the
right hand side of that path
to obtain this icon.
These key glyph functions are
being passed to the geom layer
within the ggplot
code so that we
can update these key legends
according to how they original
look.
Having done this,
the publishing house
were not quite impressed
with our skills
and try to believe in us that
we could actually do this.
The next question then
was, OK, so can you
do this in all languages?
This economics textbook
has been translated
into several languages
and so we needed
to figure out how to handle
the automatic translation
of these figures
in our pipeline.
This third step will be
focused on translation.
And the solution
that we came up with
was to capture the
translated strings
in the yaml file
which is then read
into the R script for the figure.
Yaml, if you're not
familiar with it,
used to stand for yet
another markup language
and it's now become the
recursive acronym yaml ain't
markup language to
specifically distinguish
its use as being
data oriented rather
than a traditional
markup for documents.
It's often used in
configuration files
and you might have
seen it or noticed it
at the top of R
Markdown documents.
That's yaml, it's very
structured and importantly,
it's human readable.
This is important for us because
we needed the translators who
are non-technical to be able
to easily work with the format
in order to capture
the translated strings.
But at the same time,
I have a structure that
has a clear format
to it and it's
data oriented to work with in
R. On the left hand side here,
you can see an example
from one of our yaml files.
Each of the languages is denoted
by an abbreviated two letter
word.
For example, en for English.
Each of the labels that
then requires translation
is assigned a
variable name that's
common across all
of the languages.
For example x-axis label.
The value for this
label is then the text
that is the translated string.
For example, year,
ano, of wuosi.
In R we then have
the yaml package
to work with these files.
So the strings are returned to
R using the function read _yaml
as a list of lists which are
then converted to a data frame.
Within the ggplot code,
each of the labels
that requires translation
is being substituted
with that variable name.
The list of languages
that needs to be generated
is obtained from the first
level in the hierarchy
of the yaml file.
And then I iterate
over those languages
and replace the variable names
with each translated string
as we generate the output
for that translation.
The fourth benefit
of this process
was that it allowed us to
give the translators some more
custom control over the labels.
What I mean by this
is for example,
in some cases needed some part
of the string to be in italics.
For example, the units.
With just English, this
is fairly straightforward
to do within the R script.
However, if we take multiple
languages into account,
how do we know which part of the
string needs to be in italics?
This is where I used
the ggtext package.
This is a line from
the theme function
which I shared earlier, where
we replaced the element text
function with element markdown.
What this enables is
that the translators
can use simple markdown
in their strings
which is then converted to
display the correct output
in the final image.
So for example, they could
enclose a unit in asterixis
and this is then converted into
italics in the final output.
This worked well forlabels
that were axis titles.
However, we also
have many labels
that require
translation that are
placed on the plot with
geom label or geom text.
In order to cater
for this, what I did
was again use the ggtext
package and create
a function that corresponds
with the original ggplot
to override it.
So for example,
geom text and here
we use instead geom_richtext
which again enables translators
to be able to put
simple markdown
into the strings
that's been catered
for in the final output.
One of the really
interesting challenges
to solve with the translation
was the different numbering
systems for different
languages and how
do we automatically cater
for this in a single R script.
What do I mean by this?
Well here you can
see three graphs
in three different languages.
What I want you to do is
take note of the y-axis
and the format of
each of the numbers.
On the left, we
have English and you
can see that the 1,000
separator is a comma.
We then have Spanish,
which has a space separator
but only once the number is
more than four digits long.
Then we have the
Finnish and here, you
can see that the 1,000
separator is a space.
So how do we cater for
this in the R script?
The solution I came up with was
to create a number formatting
function per language which
uses the number format function
to specify what
the big mark should
be for 1,000 separator
and the decimal mark
whether it should be
a comma or a point.
The key thing here is that
each function for each language
has the same name as the two-
letter abbreviated version
in the yaml file.
This here shows English
compared to Finnish
which is denoted by FI.
The Spanish was a slightly more
involved example and function.
And what I did here
was to iterate over
the list of numbers supplied
as the labels and first check
whether the number is more
than four digits long.
If so, then it gets a
space and otherwise there's
no space for the 1,000
separate operator.
Within the ggplot code,
within the R script,
the production of
each of the languages
is handled within
for loop and as
mentioned previously
this list of languages
is obtained from the first
level heading in the yaml file.
For example, en, es, fi.
In the ggplot code, I then used
a very handy match.fun  function
from base R that takes the
language input as a string
and then uses the number
formatting function
that corresponds with
that in order to format
the numbers for the
y-axis according to what
is needed for that language.
This here shows the y-axis
but it can just as easily
be done for the x-axis.
Having figured this
last piece of the puzzle
out on how to automatically
translate images
within our pipeline, I then
went back to the publishers
and heard a resounding,
let's do this from them.
So we are now at a
stage in the process.
We are figuring out how to
integrate with the publishing
pipeline in order to
automatically and beautifully
create thousands of images
for the economics textbook.
Peeking into our workshop
from the perspective
of the publishing
industry, what we have done
may seem incomprehensible.
But I hope what I have
demonstrated here
is that, with a few
familiar tools applied
in unconventional ways, you
can completely transform
a conventional process.
There are so many
industries and processes
out there that are
still very manual
and time intensive and
battling to keep up
with our ever-changing world.
They don't know it yet,
but they could really
benefit from your skills.
And from my experience,
they won't necessarily
come knocking at your door.
So sit up and take
notes of opportunities
where you can really add value.
For me, I'm thinking of those
economics students sitting
in their lecture venue at the
start of the academic year.
Not only would they have lived
through the previous year
however bizarre and unusual it
might have been and come out
different for it but now
the textbook can too.
Thank you, I do look forward
to your thoughts and questions
and please do get in touch.